son lieu de naissance une exploitation
agricole l'adresse impasse des
cultivateurs
autant dire que tout était réuni pour
que marie jean soit agricultrice sans
parler de son amour pour la nature et
vécu ici en fait ça fait je suis né ici
dans une sphère avec plein d'animaux de
la nature moment je cherchais le nom de
cette plante la collision
c'est la séquence montbavin chat j'ai pu
reprendre l'exploitation de vos parents
oui j'aurais pu étant donné que j'ai
grandi dessus j'ai travaillé mais jobs
d'été c'était ici sur la banane mais à
vrai dire je préfère être dans un bureau
que train crime et sous le soleil sous
la pluie alors pour être dans un bureau
marie george a choisi une toute autre
voie
elle est ingénieur dans l'aéronautique à
hambourg en allemagne pour un sous
traitant d'airbus
ce moment je suis sans projet qui permet
de la qualifier de qualifier des pièces
on doit s'assurer que les pièces
pourront suivre la durée de vie de
l'avion
donc on va passer sur des bancs de test
des bandes moins 40 mois 50 degrés et
même des températures aussi positive + 5
ans + 80 degrés et aussi des tests de
vibration donc effectivement et on ne
laisse rien au hasard dans
l'aéronautique
une classe prépa en martinique des
études en france et en finlande puis un
stage en allemagne
un parcours brillant qu'il ne sût ans
prend sa mère qu'à moitié
moi je sais que c'est un enfant qui est
qu'à être des goûts des débrouillards de
assez intelligente
voilà alors m'est arrivé à ce point est
arrivé en allemand
apprendre l'allemand tout ça je sais
petit peu parce que le timide aussi et
oui elle est timide mais je pense que
maintenant il n'est pas timide mais elle
était timide de takrit petite dernière
d'une famille de trois enfants marie
gens souhaitent aussi l'admiration de
ses nièces aimait beaucoup dans la vie
et me permet de maintenir mais qu est-ce
que l'arrêté soit 1 permet d'ailleurs de
l'avant est ce que tu veux faire comme
métier de presse
tu vas prayssas en martinique où est ce
que tu vas partir dans un autre pays
mais même si son parcours laisse rêveur
il cache aussi son lot de frustrations
j'aimerais revenir mais c'est un
problème pour moi pour venir aujourd'hui
apporter à la filière que j'ai choisi
mais ça fait des années que je postule
en martinique sur les sites les offres
d'emploi qu'on voit sur internet la
plupart du temps 80% des cas je reçois
pas de réponse et si je reçois des
réponses et sont négatifs en attendant
ce jour elle s'envole mercredi pour
l'allemagne et ne lui parlez pas de peur
en avion car elle vous répondra avec un
aplomb certain que l'avion est bien le
moyen de transport le plus sûr au monde